les enfants voilà ce qui me reste
servira il reste trois caramel dur mais
prenez les deux caramels mous l'épi 4
sucettes géantes et puis voulait
distribuer et vous allez voir françois
parce qu'il va vous donner ces derniers
ballons on est allé voir françois vite
tiens qui veut le faire voilà un bleus
un rouge et un jour on attendait j'en ai
quelques uns encore non gonflés dans
cette boîte vous permettez xap l ennemi
gérer le temps que nous connaissons je
vous en prie c'est naturel dit stop
mon vieux 10,9 à ma foi quant à moi
enfin ce qui me concerne je préférerais
que l'on continue à m'appeler monsieur
du snob
ça ne vous fasse pas trop mon émission
mais pas du tout où navan du snop
vraiment bon mais je le disais dans mon
cher et milquet les dons ce remue ménage
là bas je vois françois de distribuer
ces ballons à tort et à travers julie
être encore plus excité que d'habitude
ce qui n'est pas peu dire
et quant aux enfants ma foi les enfants
ils m'ont l'air bizarre
vous ne savez pas alors si le dernier
jour que les enfants partent avec nous
cette saison
oui ils partent en vacances mais c'est
vrai au avais je la tête mais je le
savais bonjour ma chère amy lee je sais
je sais ma chère amie c'est la veille
des vacances à je me souviens quand
j'étais jeune j'ai vu l'éclosion puis si
vous êtes gentil monsieur meunier ont
validé donc quand j'étais jeune
vous nous raconterez ça une autre
flammes ah bon très bien ça vous
intéresse pas très bien je me tais non
non
vous vexez pas monsieur du snob mais les
enfants doivent prendre le bateau dans
une demi-heure tenait cela vous fait il
plaisir de les accompagner jusqu'au bout
bien serait très grand plaisir sera mise
à l'honneur un petit peu inquiet oui oui
parce que je n'ai pas encore vu les
imitera bon eh oui je ne les ai pas vues
de la journée il devrait être là pour
dire au revoir aux enfants
oh lalalalalalalalala c'est vraiment la
journée la plus triste de l'année tous
les enfants de lits seront en vacances
et je ne vais pas les voir pendant deux
mois on s'est vraiment affreux et vous
non plus je ne verrai plus à un autre au
rendez vous que tous les jours en qu'est
ce que vous me demandez est ce que l'on
se renverra à la rentrée oui bien sûr
heureusement ça me remonte à un peu le
moral d'ailleurs pour les enfants vont
prendre le bateau il faut que j'aille or
dire au revoir avant qu'il parte
oh j'ai une idée je vais les retarder
comme ça ils vont peut-être ont raté
leurs bateaux et ils resteront sur l'île
avec moi toutes les vacances me dis que
rien attendez moi je viens vous dire au
revoir et ben alors quasiment tous
étaient des oranje faisaient une petite
sieste
le jour du départ des enfants bravo mais
rien ne presse ils ont tout leur temps
mais non justement que des mairies n'ont
pas tous leurs temps au rang et eux sont
déjà presque au revoir monsieur du snop
doit les accompagner jusqu'au tom
wheeler peter vous allez tu veux les
accompagner avec moi si tu veux gagner
non alors ces trois fronts voir pas les
voir partir en bateau sans moi allons
allons quasiment un pied de courrent
entreprise tu dis moi joël ou est-ce que
tu parles fois cette année
en normandie quelle chance tu as alors
parce qu'ils avaient dit oui ce que tu
vas à quoi en bretagne c'est très bon la
bretagne l'été vous avez vraiment de
chance un des marques du moment le pire
et vit dans les pyrénées
qu'est ce que c'est bon la montagne
l'été et agnès ou du vin serre chevalier
du mans verra des cartes postales pour
ma collection est quasiment dépêche toi
on dirait qu'il fait bien prêt n'est pas
dû arranger tous les enfants bon wagon
au revoir au revoir
vous me verrez des cartes postales un au
revoir à tous alors allez casimir que
leur avance
il faut les laisser partir c'est très
juste chers amis enfin il est temps que
nous partirons à nous vous en mairie pas
encore sinon ça fait une colère sans
casimir tu veux être raisonnable oui
tu les reverra tiens toi bien qu'ils
gardent au moins bon souvenir de toi
bon d'accord je vais bien les laisser
partir alors au revoir
on attend ça tous les enfants vont avec
malaisie aller chez vous revoir les
enfants ils ont de la chance de partir
en vacances moi aussi j'aimerais bien
aller ailleurs enfin casimir tous les
enfants ne vont pas ailleurs certains
restent chez eux et ils s'amuseront
quand même beaucoup
tout à fait d'accord avec vous julie
mais comme dit le poète
enfin en poète ailleurs l'herbe est plus
verte parole cette histoire verbe
facteurs casimir ça veut dire que tu
veux aller chercher ailleurs ce que tu
as ici regarde autour de toi tu outillés
pour passer d'excellents de la corde la
campagne la mer la montagne tout mais
vous dites vraiment n'importe quoi
renvoyant à tout ce qu'il faut ici c'est
parce que depuis un instant il manque
l'essentiel est quoi
oui mais il n'y a plus d'enfants l'île
aux enfants sans enfants sont nés
plaisir aux enfants
d'ailleurs je m'ennuie déjà c'est vrai
ça n'est pas très gentil pour nous mais
j'aimerais quand même bien parti et où
ça qui est bien
l'import pour dans un endroit où il ya
des enfants
j'ai des amis partout moi ne nous aussi
casimir mais malheureusement nous avons
beaucoup de travail dans l'île aux
enfants
il faut tout remettre en état pour la
rentrée il faut ratisser les plages
arranger le toit de mon coeur et réparer
les jouets cassés car des commodes de
boudu suspecte de ballon rond moindre
logo ou en faire le plein de bons
planter des fleurs inventer de nouveaux
jets temps pour sûr nous avons du pain
sur la planche
cela dit casimir tu es un petit peu
idiot si tout à l'heure tu nous avais
dit que je voulais partir de thorium et
c'est oui pourquoi n'es tu pas parti en
bateau avec les enfants alors si je
trouvais un moyen de quitter l'île tu me
laisserais partir françois évidemment
casimir
mais là je ne vois pas que tu pourrais
faire à moins de tlv dans les airs dans
les airs il te reste quelques ballons tu
veux bien me donner sous volontiers ça
ne les bras 7e casimir voilà merci
françois de rien après
[Musique]
bon avec ses ballons en plus je suis sûr
de m'envoler voilà bon jus dit françois
bonnet me dire au revoir je pars sàrl
mais qu'est ce que tu fais dans cette
nasse alors et pourquoi yatuu accrocher
mes ballons et bien grâce à ce ballon
aérostat était ballon en plus je vais
pouvoir me voler et partir en vacances
s'ils croient que ça va marcher mais
évidemment il me reste plus qu'à ajouter
les sacs de l'est voilà c'est des sacs
de sable blanc je jette ça et je déconne
attention c'est pas la seule dernier ça
au revoir au revoir mais ça alors mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe bien évidemment
il reste des ça allait à cette fois ça y
est au revoir
sarah long mais tu ne crois pas tu tues
un peu trop lourd casimir moi je crois
que pour que ça marche il faudrait que
du père d'au moins 10 euros
au moins 90 kg il n'y a pas assez de
ballons alors je vais être obligée de
rester un oui pour la peine je mangerai
pour les jours de gloubiboulga autant
que je veux lacker et puis et puis je ne
ferai rien de tout les aînés promis un
combat long ballon mais ballon tombe à
l'eau salée casimir casino va
ne soit pas trop triste de toute façon
tu n'aurais pas su s'en servir
allez viens avec nova qui va nous aider
dans notre travail
hier justin tu peux tu sais où il a
calmement fouilles
bon moi puisque je pour rester là je
veux bien vous donner un petit coup de
main histoire
enfin heureusement que tout est bien qui
finit bien les enfants n'ont pas encore
pu durer vous que le moteur du bateau
est tombé en panne juste avant le départ
heureusement qu'il y avait le mécanicien
du port elle a dit que ce n'était pas
grave il est en train de devenir la
réparation alors françois qui m'a bien
dit tout à l'heure que si je pouvais
partir avec les enfants
tu me donnerait la permission évidemment
casimir mais alors j'y vais pour voir
des pêcheries oran françois forme aussi
envers la chauray et travailler bien que
tout soit impeccable pour mon tour
ok donc d'accord c'est à dire au revoir
au bradage casini tonnes date ans